have you been to Sacramento yet hell no
I going out there on that some with CML
we we Ain get I'm out of bounds baby on
the gang I ain't going with Chito I
ain't going with them I ain't going
nobody I stay down south I I was going
to say like if you get booked up there
you going to take the booking or no I'm
taking the straps I'm taking the straps
I ain't going out there I'm way out of
bounds I wouldn't want to even touch
grounds right there oh I would people on
the blog saying that oh he's disy nor so
what I am disy nor and I would never go
up there I'm not stupid and you would
never come down here well I've noticed
like a lot of the a lot of the ogs are
uniting from the south and the north I
don't want to speak on the ogs I don't
speak on Prison politics prisons prisons
the streets is the streets but I talk
about music we're talking music wise
whatever they got going hey I I listen
to that my politics are different I
don't speak on that right so what I
speak on though is music wise people say
nor are better than Southside rappers
this is for music they're not they're
not they're hard I don't bump none of
this stuff you know what I'm saying and
they stay dissing the homies so why is
everybody all but her that I'm saying
[__] them cuz they stay dissing us you
know what I'm saying they stay dissing
us calling us you know what I'm saying
that's cool so each is his own I'm going
make music from my side hey shout outs
ha the world man Blue Devil I like the
way he puts it he just keeps it real dog
and he makes me see it the way that I
see it but I just can't get the words
out but he just like I it's a big topic
it's everybody saying Lefty says I I
would never do a song with them I would
never go up there and go to their side
of town and I don't think they would
ever come down south I never seen a
northel oh never mind I'm not going to
say nothing that's another subject I
never I never leave it like that my
question to you is uh I know you been
putting out a lot of videos a lot of
singles freestyles are you working on an
album right now yeah [__] rap dog I
think about it right there just drinking
just looking at it like of the year of
the Year [__] rapie of the Year Rookie
of the Year and I'll still sell it out
that's the album The album's called
Rookie of the Year it's hard so the
album's called Rookie of the Year Rookie
of the Year it's the best [__] that I
ever wrote in my life they got my sound
out of me all this [__] you guys think
is hard hell no you get a preview with
like the greul stuff just the the the
Cheeto flow like those are like the
songs they just add and they're getting
like 150,000 70 80,000 in one day on
YouTube I trip off hey how much does
start from scratch got right now please
while I do it yeah Rookie of the Year
man Lefty Gunplay by OTR records
produced by Z Keys South Trey Matt
bricks all cypers what features you got
oh man I got big sad 1900 I got Drummer
Boy I Got King cash I got1 hours 9,000
that ain't [__] it's probably more than
that that ain't nothing the views ain't
caught up yet you got to look at that
from the YouTube Studio he knows he
knows erase it and that sounds hard I
want to hear right now yeah shit's hard
hey no um big sad Lil wo Lil Maru um
shout out San Diego Shout Out Lil Maru
we're doing the baby I can't keep my
eyes off you and
I'm but he's writing when he's writing
and I'm going I got a thing for the Rock
and Ro pack you in the yeah that was the
Big Gemini record right remix that that
beat and uh that's the song that I told
him I wanted him on I see him on it and
I think he's going to do numbers him see
so when you when you do that record you
got to hit a big Gemini to get it
cleared you got to just remake the beat
dog to whoever can make the beat better
memorize it in your are y'all clearing
the Big Gemini sample y yeah through
George
Mexico yeah they said it's good that's
just hard That's a classic going do
money y'all got to remake some NB Rider
[__] no MC Magic
[__] that that say baby no I know but
I'm saying you should also remake some
MC like did you ever grow up listening
to MC Magic all my girls did all my mom
did my mom and all her home girls did
yeah that's like the girls and the mom
stuff like uh nah can't oh yeah I should
do it for the people why not for the
culture yeah for the culture they would
really like that shout outs to other
girls that grew up up listening to that
and I'm like you should you should do a
free hey you know what we're going to
have You Freestyle before you leave over
I'mma pick the beat let me hear which be
we're going to do neighborhood music a
little Rie yeah I think that'll be hard
damn that one's going to be hard to do
and then like then some all right or we
can do summer nights that's it no or or
neighborhood neighborhood oh I could do
it like that I like this neighborhood
it's all good we'll get to that later
it'll be it right now already well no
it'll be a different YouTube video I met
L Rob the other day man shout out to L
Rob man manot took me over there to a to
a l Rob concert on a Sunset Boulevard in
Mel Rose yeah um he took me I met him he
was real humble he's just like real like
just a hum you know I me Sao local too
like sa sao's cool he's cool as [__] too
yeah he's really cool he's like gang
gang like he's just like Hood with it
like he's just he is Woody like he says
he's just like he's he's a gangster s
Bo's a gangster like you meet him in
person you'll be like oh [__] he a gang
he real woman Recognize Real he he he a
l like he a gangster you know I always
wondered is I didn't think he was going
to be like that I he surprised the [__]
out of me he's really like that like
he's just really tripping sa Boy Lo I
met him randomly backstage at a y
concert in Arizona before he went to
jail the last time he's cool huh I mean
he was cool yeah he look like a homie
like yeah that's Boy Lo shout outy Lo
yg4 uh I was rest in PE SL man I was
going to ask you yeah rip to slim 400 uh
for you like being in the shoe I wonder
mentally what do you do to not go crazy
when you're in that sort of confinement
man cuz I just went crazy to break you
right it did it didn't I didn't even do
that long in there people did 20 30
years you know I don't want to say too
much on it I did two three years I have
no phone no no soups no that mentally
like are you able to mentally go on a
vacation and remove think pedin Bay Sho
was like more boring than Cork and shoe
Quirk and shoe I had like a good time in
there Quirk and Sho is just like just
cool it's just like it's like you just
got to be ready for your [__] but Cork
and Sho just Cork and shoe you just got
to go to Cork and shoe to know Cork and
shoe no wor could explain it I've been
to Cork and shoe I went to Cork and shoe
for like you know young grew up in Cork
and shoe 18 19 20 boom transferred
pelicin Bas shoe year and a half boom
hit the line but I was in Cork and
shoe [__] was cool right there dog it's
just like a different type of time in my
life like just really [__] me up just
really made me better just I just
tripped out on it I look back at it like
that [__] [__] you up though like it's
just like it's a trip and made me who I
am and I got no regrets but yeah I
wasn't Cork and shoe has it has it been
hard like how long did it take for you
if you even have adjusted to like being
out I don't think I could do cork and
shoe over again it was just like that
that that was like that vicious like you
just got to have the heart for the first
time and do it one time and that's it
it's just Cork and shoe breaks
[__] like it's just good homies
and the homies right there just real
tight but corking shoes just corking
shoot I don't miss that thing I do not
and then how how hard has it been being
now learning how to adapt is what you
ask me yeah learning how to adapt U um
being so institutionalized still being
in the hood just yeah I got a bag I got
money but money don't last forever like
you know I took care of my knees and a
right now I got an apartment and I'm
just waiting to sign I don't know why my
mom she's like just lagging to sign but
yeah just I got to get out the hood I'm
dying to get up out the hood like people
want to be Hood so bad I'm I don't want
this no more I'm going to be Hood to
keep a ghetto D to the hood but man like
but that's also where you're the most
vulnerable at the hood is always the
hood don't ever take it for granted dog
like you live by the gun you die by the
gun I'm not stupid I'm really ganga and
God already wrote the script you can't
be scared when you go you go just when
it's your time it's your time and if
you're not asking for trouble you just
you know on your Lon on some gang [__]
you be all right but if you're out there
looking for trouble trouble going to
find you D homies I don't care what area
you in like you know what I'm saying you
in the county you on the streets you
want in another person's Hood you be
popping it for you you better be walking
it like fools out there ain't playing I
don't get to twist it people out there
ain't playing I wasn't playing you know
what I'm saying it's it's bad out here
in La too like you know what I'm saying
but it's also good but if you look for
trouble you w't find trouble to the kids
doing it like don't do that like listen
to your mom this is [__] and and are
you you feel like you're moving in a way
in which like hey I'm stay yeah I'm like
like you know you you don't want you
don't you don't want to end up it hurts
back or even dead I don't give a [__]
though like I don't care if I ended up
dead or ended up back I don't I'm not
doing that I'm being smart about it I
know I got [__] going on for me for
myself but if something were to happen
and that happened [__] it that's what
happened that's the way the script went
and we're we're doing everything not to
do that and that's the part it's hard of
as long as you're doing those things
right it's hard though no that's why I
got to tap Pat myself in the Bo and back
and nobody gives me that credit like
them two steps back like not kicking it
with the Hood um not being not setting
dope no more right right you can't sell
dope and rap that's [__] cuz you're
going to be strapped serving up sexs all
day you'll never get in the zone you
want to rap you got to sacrifice and be
broke dog and write them B in jail and
just believe in your dream dog and stop
being selling dop dope's cool selling
dope's cool you I never made past
[__] $500,000 in my pocket to where I
was just breaking even every day and
just you know had a brand new shirt and
a chain and a beamer I had a beamer you
know what I'm saying but a haircut but
no real well nothing that's the same
thing every weekend I haircut that's all
I had but I had money though right but
now I got money